(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Rhett.
Ha, gotcha.
I'm Link.
- I think you got yourself.
- (chuckles) No I didn't.
I fooled you, man.
- Well--
- Is that why we
introduce ourselves at the
beginning of the podcast
so that we--
- It would have fooled me--
- We know who we are, or is it for them?
- Yeah I would have gotten you.
- It's for the listener.
- You can't get me if I go first.
This is a fundamental misunderstanding.
If I said welcome to
Ear Biscuits, I'm Link,
I would have gotten you.
But I already said my name so
you saying that you're Rhett
is getting no one--
- You know what?
- Except the Mythical Beasts.
- I'll get you next week.
- Okay, I'm ready.
- I'm gonna get you.
There's nothing you can do to prepare.
- Now I know that you're gonna do it.
I am prepared.
- I'll still get you.
- Okay.
- I'll still get ya.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the question
what is the greatest game show
of all time?
At least according to me and separately
but equally according to Link.
- Oh that's funny.
- Don't say something's funny.
Either laugh or don't.
But don't say that's funny.
- Yeah we have ranked--
- So insulting.
- We have ranked our top five game shows.
- And we haven't looked
at each other's lists.
- And made a list of honorable mentions
because it wasn't necessarily
that easy to do that
so we're gonna go through
that, compare notes.
- Can I just say that, you may say oh,
who cares about game shows?
I don't even know why
I'm listening to this
but I will say I'm personally offended
because this is a deeply
personal topic for me.
As I think will become clear very quickly
when I go through my list,
game shows are tied in
not only to my psyche and
not only to by the way
what we do for a living now in terms
of formatting Good Mythical
Morning, I think there's a lot,
we haven't plumbed the
depths, maybe we will today,
of how the game show
culture and our experiences
with it have shaped Good Mythical Morning.
But even if we don't
get to it, it is a fact.
But even more importantly,
there's a certain part
of my childhood, actually a couple of eras
in my childhood that are deeply
associated with game shows.
- Well and I also think
it will be interesting
because my theory is that your criteria
for what makes a good game
show is probably different
than mine and maybe there
ends up being some crossover
because of that and maybe not.
- Or maybe we'll just fight.
- So I am excited about this discussion.
We do wanna let you know
that we are coming your way
if you happen to be in one
of the following places
on the following dates.
Yes, again, this musical
comedy tour that we're doing
right now which is not
the Tour of Mythicality.
People are still calling it that.
The Tour of Mythicality
was a distinct thing
that was related to the first book.
This is a musical concert experience
that we're having Britton Buchanan,
Link's cousin from The
Voice opening up for us
and anecdotal evidence as
told to us by Mythical Beasts
that we met while on tour last time,
have told us that they prefer this show
to the Tour of Mythicality so
I would say eight out of 10,
nine out of 10, maybe 10 out of 10.
- Yeah, prefer it.
- There was a couple people who said--
- 10 out of 10 dentists prefer--
- Yeah, especially if you're
a dentist, you should come.
- Rhett and Link live in concert
versus the Tour of Mythicality.
If you liked that, you'll love this.
- And again--
- If you didn't like it,
you'll love this.
- We're gonna be in Las Vegas
on Friday, June 21st, we're
gonna be in Salt Lake City
on June 22nd, we're gonna
be in Denver, Colorado
on June 23rd, we're gonna be
in Milwaukee on June 25th,
Indianapolis June 26th,
Detroit on June 27th,
Omaha on June 29th and
Minneapolis on June 30th.
- Come out and see us!
And if you know someone
who's in these areas,
tell them to come out and see us.
- 'Cause that's what we run into.
What we have found is every
time we're visiting a town
and we're walking around
before a show or after a show
or whatever, people are
like Rhett and Link,
what are you doing here?
And we're like well we got a
show and they're like what?
- Or we had a show, that's even sadder.
- Yeah so we're letting you know now so--
- You can let them know now.
- Go to RhettAndLinkLive.com
to get your tix.
- Get your tix.
You got something for me
before we get into game shows?
- Yeah I do.
I'm feeling not a little bit jittery
because I am--
- Does that mean not
jittery or a lot jittery?
- I'm a lot jittery.
- Okay.
- I am on sort of the
second half of day two of,
and I'm not gonna say the brand because
I haven't finished this yet so I'm not
in the mood for an endorsement.
I don't know if this is gonna be something
that I will then
recommend to other people.
But you know, I like to try
new things and experiment
with new things and I'm
kinda into the whole like--
- If this is illegal,
we should talk offline.
- (chuckles) It's not illegal.
I'm into the whole anti-aging thing
and I've been doing the
intermittent fasting thing
for almost two months now.
- Which is?
- Basically eating
for an eight hour period
and then not eating
for a 16 hour period, super, actually,
a lot of people here are
doing it at the office.
It's really popular.
- If that makes you feel better about it.
- At least in this town.
- Sure.
- So here's what I'll say.
I can give it--
- Group think.
- A two month in endorsement
of intermittent fasting
has radically transformed
some things about my body.
And I'm not talking about like body shape,
I'm talking about like inflammation.
I got little spots of
psoriasis that pop up,
those have dwindled.
I have this recurrent
sort of like unpredictable
bowel reactions to things, you know,
if we eat something weird on the show
or if I eat something really spicy,
that has stabilized and all the five times
that I've had hot chicken
in the past couple weeks,
absolutely no negative effects from it.
I have to believe that
this is somewhat related.
- You've been freed up to
say yes every single time
that you're remotely
presented with the opportunity
to sample a hot chicken.
- And that means a lot to me.
- We're walking down the
street and you just stop,
you said, I'll meet up with you later.
I'm gonna be in this hot chicken place
that we just happened to stumble on
even though we'd just eaten lunch.
- And getting the hottest one.
Still no effect.
- Again, this is not the thing
that you're not endorsing.
This is intermittent fasting
which means you're waking up
in the morning, you're
not eating breakfast.
- You eat, you pick an eight hour.
I'm doing the 16 and eight so basically,
I wake up in the the morning,
I don't eat until noon
and then I don't eat after eight o'clock.
And basically--
- After eight o'clock
would be easy but I don't
think I could wait until noon
to eat, I get--
- I was never, I don't wake up hungry
so that wasn't a big deal for me.
- What about if you go to
the gym and then afterward,
aren't you starving?
You gotta build muscle, man.
- Yeah but you adjust
pretty quickly to that.
And it doesn't--
- You drink, right?
- Drink water, yeah.
- Just water.
- Yeah or you can have tea.
There's some people who
are really sticklers,
who are like, you can have like some BCAAs
like branched-chain amino
acids and stuff like that,
they don't really hit the calorie.
- Okay you're losing me.
- For me that's really complicated
because I don't wanna be
the dad who doesn't eat dinner,
you know what I'm saying
so this way I can still
eat dinner which makes me
not a weird person.
- Great movie though.
- (chuckles) The dad who
would not eat dinner.
- It's in black and white
but you get used to that
after like the opening
scene which is amazing.
It's a dad and he's at the table
but he's not eating dinner.
- Right but he's present.
- Everybody else is there eating dinner.
- He just watches you as you eat.
- Yeah it was hilarious.
- It's better than just
watching TV while you eat.
- They hated it, they hated it.
- But--
- That's the start
of the character arc.
- So you have a difficult
time in the morning.
Late at night, that is my time.
That's what's been difficult to me is
I am a late night snacker
and so stopping eating
basically at eight o'clock,
essentially after dinner,
that has been a difficult adjust to me
so I go to bed hungry.
- But you haven't even
gotten to the thing.
- No, but the thing that I
am trying now is this thing,
it's called the fasting mimicking diet
that these professors,
or a professor at USC
partnered with some anti-aging institute
and they came up, they
formulated this diet.
- If that makes you feel better about it.
- It's a five, it does, well
it's not just some hack,
it's like scientific from
a legitimate establishment.
They formulated a diet--
- ULCA.
Oh, nope.
- That tricks your body into
thinking that it is fasting,
so when you fast, all this stuff happens.
Like all the science is showing right now
that during a period of fasting,
there's like all these
things that are happening
to your body and organs
shrinking and cell removal
and stuff like that that
the research is beginning
to kinda line up with this
is a really healthy thing
for people to do.
But fasting just cold turkey
is a difficult thing to do
and also probably, I don't
really know all the reasons
why they want you to have
a little bit of calories
but not go cold turkey
but I think that it's just
an easier transition for people.
I like systems like I can
just get a box of food
and just be like I don't
have to think about this.
I literally look at a picture,
like a little print out--
- I do like that.
- You have to eat
the three things, you get
a little box for every day.
Eat these three things at breakfast,
these three things at lunch,
these three things in the afternoon.
- A pre-schooler could do it.
- But the things that
I'm eating are like a bar
and I'm not doing the fasting mimicking
and the intermittent fasting
because I have to keep up
with breakfast, lunch and
dinner just so you know.
- Had to switch gears,
had to switch tracks.
- All that to say that
it's not enough food.
- Well I looked over
your shoulder yesterday
and you were finishing a bowl
of juice with seeds in it
is what it looked like to me.
- Soup.
I just put it in--
(Link sputters)
- (laughs) Soup.
- I put it in a--
- It didn't look like soup,
man, it was jelly-like.
- Well the reason you interpreted
it as a drink is because
I had it in a mason jar, but
it was minestrone. (chuckles)
It wasn't necessarily good minestrone.
Actually it tasted excellent
in the state that I was in but--
- You're basically doing a
hospital recovery mimic diet.
Like if you're recovering from something
and they put you on this weird,
bland, watery diet of some--
- And there's packs of, the
reason that a lot of people,
including you, wouldn't be able to do this
is that one of the things
that you get twice a day
is a pack of olives.
- Oh God!
- And actually I've never had so much fun
with a pack of olives.
- What have you been doing with it?
- Well, just eating it, believe it or not.
And it's like six olives.
I already like olives
but when you're barely eating anything,
a package of six olives is heaven.
I might just have--
- I would be eatin'--
- Little small packs of
olives from here on out.
- You eat the pit?
You're that hungry.
- No, they're de-pitted.
Or they're pitted.
- Yeah because they're afraid
that you'll eat it.
I mean here's the thing about fasting.
I think goes back to
hunter-gatherer type situation
where you're like, you get
desperate to find some,
you're like hunting, you're out there
and your organs are shrinking
and your body's getting sinewy
and you're pulling back your bow string
and trying to get a deer,
man, and you know what,
and you're desperate.
- But that is the science
behind it is that people
say that, and again,
I don't know, I haven't
read enough about this
to make any endorsements or
what's true or what's not true.
- Why read about it when
you can eat about it?
- When you can just do it.
The thinking behind the
whole fasting thing is that
humans traditionally, back in
those hunter-gatherer days--
- It wasn't like constantly rolling over
and stuffing your face.
- You didn't have three
square meals per day.
You ate when it was plentiful,
that's one of the reasons we have such a,
we abuse fats and sugars
because it wasn't often--
- Instinct.
- That you came across fats
and sugars and if you came
across a calorie-dense thing,
you ate it.
- Capitalize, buddy.
- But now we're just
surrounded by calorie-dense things
and so we're all out of whack, anyway--
- But my problem, I think
the risk with the fasting
is that you might find yourself
attacking and eating things.
- You better watch out.
- Like if you try to eat
Jade, I will kill your.
I would not hesitate.
It would be instinctive, again,
it would be like one of those--
- I'm not gonna kill--
- It would be like
a hunter-gatherer fight to the death.
Would you eat my dog?
- I can make a promise.
- Don't eat my dog.
- I am not going to kill--
- Like a cartoon, look at my dog--
- Your dog in the next four days.
- Looks like a cooked turkey, you know?
- I will not kill your dog--
- Eat your own dog, man.
- In these circumstances,
but in the apocalypse,
in desperate times, if I've
already eaten someone else's dog
and the only thing left
is your dog and my dog?
I'll probably eat your dog.
- Yeah I think in an
apocalyptic situation,
the dogs that you wanna
keep around are the ones
that are ferocious.
You don't wanna keep around
the emotional support dogs.
I think they become like (chuckles),
emotional support dogs are
the first things that become
hunger support dogs. (chuckles)
- Right well there's, I don't
watch The Walking Dead anymore
but there's not a dog in that show, right?
Was there a dog?
- There's a lot of union
stipulations when you bring
in the dogs and the kids.
- Right.
- I think that's why they
started killing the kids too.
Early on they killed the kids--
- I'll tell ya right now.
- 'Cause they have to
bring in tutors and stuff.
- I'm jittery, I can only
imagine how bad your shakes,
I think I probably have equal
shakes to you right now.
- I'm steady as a painter.
- Why are you moving so much then?
For those of you listening,
we're holding our hands
next to each other,
seeing who's shakier.
It's pretty even right now.
Anyway I'll report back
and let you know how I feel
at the end of the week.
- Why not at the end of this episode?
Let's just contain it right here.
- Okay yeah, well, I'll
still be on day two.
- All right so let's get
into our game show list
now that I've thoroughly picked
apart your minestrone diet.
(chuckles)
- But first, we wanna let
you know that you can grab
the hat that Link is wearing
or at least one very much
like it at Mythical.store.
These mugs are also there.
Well nothing else that
you're wearing currently
or that I'm wearing is available there
but there's a lot of stuff available.
The pin, well that pin you
gotta be in the Mythical Society
to get that pin.
- That's right.
- Mythical.store for
all your Mythical needs.
- I think Feldman was just
pointing at his nipple.
- Oh, well the shirt you're wearing.
- Nope.
- No.
- Well listen, we'll
sell anything if we can
so just go over there and
find whatever it is now.
- Lots of stuff.
- Mythical.store,
rep your boys, internetainment
supportage happening.
Go for it.
Go for it and come back full.
Kinda like Rhett at the end
of an eight hours of eating.
- Right.
Give me your philosophy
of how you chose these.
What was your guiding principal?
- My guiding principal
for my top five game shows
of all time was enjoyment
factor coupled with
I just think sentimental
slash personal connection.
So do you wanna just start?
- I wanna give, okay,
that's your philosophy.
- I have some honorable
mentions, yeah, I should ask,
what's your philosophy, sorry.
I should have asked that.
- And this is--
- That's what polite people
would have done.
- Okay 'cause I figured that it had to do,
'cause you talk about game shows a lot
especially when you were a kid watching.
Interestingly, watching
game shows and not watching
any movies that everyone
else on earth was watching
which if you were wondering
why Link didn't see
Back to the Future, Top
Gun, Ghostbusters, Goonies,
fill in the blank every
single movie that you saw
when you were a child, he
was watching game shows.
- No I was watching--
- And Entertainment Tonight.
- Yeah, my mom and I watched
Entertainment Tonight
every single night at 7:30 I guess it was.
Maybe seven o'clock.
Yeah there was a point
where during the summer,
Mom would drop me off
at Nana and Papa's house
and Nana just worked a few blocks away
as a dental assistant.
No one was watching me
but Nana would come in
at lunch, like she could
leave the dental office
and come home and make
lunch for me and her
and then Papa who was police
officer, chief of police,
he would also come home.
- Really?
- Which meant he'd come home
and we'd eat lunch together
and then she would be home
pretty early in the afternoon.
I don't know how that
happened but the dental stuff
kinda slowed down around 3:30.
Kinda like school or something.
I don't know.
- Really?
- But in the mornings,
I would watch the USA Network.
And they would just have
syndicated game shows.
From years earlier so like from...
It was the late '80s when I
was watching these game shows
but they were from the early '80s or '70s.
I would watch reruns of The
Tonight Show with Johnny Carson
right when I would get there, on USA.
That's how I watched Johnny
Carson every single day,
learned all of his bits
and everything about that
so those were all reruns from the '70s.
- But at the time his show was on--
- At night.
- At night every night.
- Yeah which I didn't stay up and watch
as an upper grade schooler.
- And of course because
we were friends with Ben,
Ben--
- He would stay up.
- If you spent the night at Ben's house,
you stayed up and you
watched Johnny Carson.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause Ben just had
those kinds of tastes.
- I never spent the night
at Ben's house by the way.
- Really?
- Never once, yeah.
I mean you guys were that
much, you were a lot closer
than we were, so I would
hear about Johnny Carson
and Letterman, he also liked Letterman.
But I watched the older Johnny Carsons
because they were
syndicated on USA Network
and when those were done,
the game shows would begin
for like, probably at least
three hours of game shows
so six game shows.
Some of them made my list,
some of them made my honorable mentions.
- Yeah you shouldn't mention any of them
because then they might know,
don't know your list yet.
- That's special to me and then--
- Your awareness of game shows
and your attachment are--
- So a whole summer--
- Are related to that.
- Yeah, related to that summer.
- Whereas I think that my experience
with game shows is probably...
I think it represents
most people's interaction
with game shows in that
I watched them when they came on
in primetime or in the
afternoon or whatever.
Saw those reruns but I
think my list is generated,
it comes from the game shows
that I actually enjoyed
personally and with my family
and I think that the ones
that I just kinda noticed this
after I compiled my list,
the ones that I had put
as my top five, the thing
that I value the most
about game shows is
the play-along-ability.
- Okay.
- And it's interesting 'cause I think--
- I value, I think that--
- And I would say that
you don't value that as much as I do.
- I don't, I value something else more
and I learned it from
looking at my own list
only after I'd made it so let's
start with your number five.
I have honorable mentions,
maybe they're on your list.
- Number five, Wheel of Fortune.
- Wheel of Fortune.
Wheel of Fortune is one
of the longest-running
game shows in history.
Of course it is the nightly
follow-up to Jeopardy.
Why am I saying this like
you don't already know.
Who wouldn't know this stuff?
- Potentially the or...
Potentially the most popular
game show of all time.
If not tied with a couple other ones
that might have made our lists.
I mean it has all the ingredients, right,
it's got a charismatic, funny host.
It has Vanna White.
So it has the sex appeal.
- Oh yeah.
From Myrtle Beach.
- Of a woman
from Myrtle Beach.
- South Carolina.
I wonder what dress
she's gonna wear today.
- Right and--
- I bet there's sequins
all over her dressing room.
I bet you you couldn't vacuum
'em up, it's like glitter.
- No no sequins are way
better than glitter.
- But for her I'm just saying
they're like deeply ingrained.
I bet she has sequins
on her skin permanently,
like scales on a fish.
- I actually think
she had them attached at some point.
- Right.
- I think Vanna White's skin
is sequins.
- So if something rips,
there's still sequin under there.
- Yeah.
- I think that's what it is.
- It has a very high
play-along-ability factor.
- Yeah, and accessibility.
- And it's very accessible.
The rules are really easy to understand.
- You gotta know English and words.
- And everyone thinks that they can do it.
Unlike Jeopardy.
- Right.
Jeopardy's interesting.
I'm sure we'll get to Jeopardy.
- We'll talk about Jeopardy.
But anyway, and of course at one point,
so Pat Sajak of course was a weatherman
before he was the host of Wheel of Fortune
and he was a Los Angeles-based weatherman.
I think I've told the story before.
- I would love to meet him.
- And my dad kind of, in my mind,
looked like Pat Sajak and I swear to you--
- As a kid, yeah.
- There was a time when
I was watching the
weather and I told my mom,
I was 100% convinced that
my dad was on television.
(chuckles)
I thought yeah, they'd make
him up a little bit different
for television so he
doesn't look quite the same.
This was when I was in California.
- 38, you were 38 years old.
- Yeah it was a couple years ago.
- She used to turn the letters manually.
- Now she just touches 'em.
- They would light up
and then she would have to
walk over there and turn 'em.
And now they light up and
then when she touches them,
they change.
- How do you think she does it?
- But I don't think she does anything.
- Hold on.
- I think there's just someone
who times it, I don't
think it's a touch screen,
I'm just making that note.
- But okay especially back
when she used to turn them,
she did it so quickly.
If it's a huge phrase, how
does she know so quickly
what letters to go to?
Is she seeing it somewhere else?
Do they do something
that only Vanna can see
on the letters--
- Like Google Glass.
- Well I'm not talking about
like augmented reality.
They definitely didn't
have that back in the '80s.
But I'm saying how do you think she knows?
- Feldman and I agree,
I think they lit up.
- Oh they just light up?
- And then she would
just turn 'em.
- Okay yeah but now,
they light up when she touches 'em.
- No, they light up and--
- They light up and then
she touches 'em.
- Yeah same thing.
- Okay so her job is super easy.
- Yes, you're kinda--
- In my mind I just thought--
- [Link] You're giving her lots of credit.
- How does she know to do this?
- I think, I don't want to--
- Okay they just light up.
- Belittle what she does
because she does a lot.
- She still has a very important job.
- She walks and she touches
letters that if she didn't,
if she wasn't there, they
would still be revealed.
- Right, it's the touch of Vanna,
it's the touch of Vanna that,
oh you said they still would be revealed.
Well I'm sorry.
I believe that Vanna's
touch is what reveals that.
- I just remembered another
game show I'm adding to my,
might have to go in my top five.
No it can't, it's an honorable mention.
- Okay so Wheel of Fortune,
did it make your list?
Or did you already tell me this?
- Wheel of Fortune didn't make my list
as an honorable mention.
If they still had the thing at the end
where you could take
your winnings and shop,
remember a thing would open
and then all of a sudden,
there'd be all this
stuff with price tags--
- Yeah.
- And you could shop!
- The shopping spree.
- If you could do the friggin'
shopping spree, they've honed
it down so much that like--
- Well they've just taken
away the shopping spree.
That's all they've honed.
- No, they also at the end,
the final puzzle is like,
R, S, T, L, N, E, let's
put those up there.
We know you're gonna guess those anyway.
For decades people would just guess those.
- That's called fine-tuning.
- So now you're like, it was inevitable,
you have to do that but I
think if someone time traveled
from Vanna turning the letters
physically days 'til now,
no shopping spree, none of that,
that'd be very disappointing,
be like whoa this is--
- Yeah that's too much change too fast.
You have to slowly evolve a
game show to keep that audience.
I mean my parents still
watch it every night.
- It's an indictment of us as a society
that it has to be so streamlined.
- I think you're being
too hard on it, man.
- Didn't make my list.
I would love to meet Pat Sajak
and we've said it before,
I want to go on as a duo.
- Yeah, friends episode.
- When they did a friends episode.
Rhett and Link, we're friends,
we wanna go on Wheel of Fortune.
Come on, Pat, come on Vanna.
I'm sure Vanna, that you do
a lot more than we realize
and we're sorry.
- I thought that you had
a special system for selecting the letter
so just so you know.
- I bet you do.
I bet she's the one writing
all the puzzles, by the way.
- Yeah I would love to go on that show.
- I will do nothing but
positive, you will be number one
on my list if we get to be on it.
- Okay.
- All right Feldman,
this just in.
- She's given the answers--
- But they still light up.
- See?
- One time Vanna remembers--
- I don't think they light up.
- Turning around
the wrong letter but she
does know the solutions
to the puzzles ahead of time.
- Hold on but it's not as
simple as they just light up,
guys, there's something else going on.
We're gonna have to watch clips of this.
- My number five is a
game show that I watched
on the USA Network in
that timeframe as a kid,
Bumper Stumpers.
You ever heard of this?
- Is that when you're trying
to do the license plates?
- Well you can probably
guess but do you remember it?
Yeah that's what it is.
- I'm not guessing, I'm
trying to remember if
that's the right thing, yes.
- You've seen it?
Okay.
- It's where they--
- I didn't know if you would have seen it.
- It's like the vanity
plates and you're trying
to figure out what they mean.
- Yeah and I can't
remember who the host was.
I looked it up, this
is a Canadian game show
that they syndicated.
Al Dubois.
- Oh yeah, ol' Dubois.
- What a Canadian name.
Well it's a French name.
- From Montreal.
- Al Dubois, yeah I
love the Bumper Stumpers
and I always thought
man, one day I'll be able
to get a vanity plate, and
then when the time came,
I was like I ain't
gettin' no vanity plate.
- It's extra, costs extra.
- It costs extra.
- And it's extra.
- Yeah and it is extra.
I just remember lovin' it.
I just think it's simple,
I think it needs to be recognized more.
I think it's something
that you play all the time
and it's difficult to come
up with a good vanity plate
in real life but how
much more difficult is it
to create an entire game
show where it's like,
you're makin' it happen.
It was fun.
- That's actually in your--
(chuckles)
That made your top five.
- They turned vanity plates into
an entire game show in Canada.
- Okay first of all--
- That's a feat, man.
- Incredibly high
play-along-ability factor.
So because--
- And when people are guessing
it's kinda fun to watch
them try to sound it out.
- What else happened?
- I don't remember.
- At least you could win a car, right?
- I remember that there were
a lot of car sound effects.
(mimics car honking)
(chuckles)
I like sound effects.
Don't ask me anything else about it
'cause I don't remember--
- That gives me some clues
as to what else is gonna be on your list
if you like sound effects.
- I wanted it to be
recognized as my number five.
What's your number four?
- Not Bumper Stumpers believe it or not.
Hollywood Squares.
- Hollywood Squares.
- Is my number four.
We've ended up talking
about Hollywood Squares
quite a bit as we've
actually tried to figure out
what a modern-day version of
Hollywood Squares would be
because you had the celebrity
factor, and of course,
those of you who don't know,
Hollywood Squares is
essentially tic-tac-toe.
Two people are playing
tic-tac-toe against one another
and the way you get your letter,
either X or O on the board
is the host asks a celebrity
who's in that spot a question
and then you have to decide
if you're going to agree
or disagree with that.
- They answer the question
and then they'll, yeah you'll
have to agree or disagree.
- And they're either purposely, you.
Or they are answering it
correctly and you have to judge
the personality and of
course for many years,
was it Joan Rivers was the middle square?
- Yeah.
- Which is the most important square.
- I gotta jump in here and
say I'm pretty disappointed.
- Pretty disappointed, why?
- For a couple of reasons.
- Okay.
- I'm disappointed that it's
not higher on your list.
- Oh really?
- And I think it should be
and I think it will be after
I talk some more about it.
- All right.
- But you also stole
my thunder.
- (laughs) Okay.
- That's why I'm also upset 'cause--
- I'm sorry.
- This is my number one!
Ladies and gentlemen, my number
one, stealin' my thunder.
- This is your number one?
- It's bound to happen.
The way we do the system is
there's no buildup to number one
'cause the chances of the
other person putting it lower
really takes the wind out of a reveal.
- No that just makes it
more fun, you know what,
you get to the exciting thing earlier.
- It's like putting the shopping spree
at the top of Wheel of Fortune.
- Well they should have tried that.
Maybe it'd still be on the
air, ha, just kidding, it is.
- My number one game show
is Hollywood Squares.
- Okay.
- And I watched this religiously.
I'm pretty sure it was
on that USA situation.
And I didn't realize why until I guess now
that I think about it or
when we were talking about it
about a year ago 'cause we
were talking about game shows
and developing ideas
for game shows honestly.
The comedic factor, the fact that someone
could intentionally try to deceive you
or there's different ways to play it
and some people were just celebrities
and they were just playing it sincere.
Some of them were acting sincere
but they were playing you.
And some of 'em, the comedians
on there like Jim J. Bullock,
I don't know who that
guy is except that he was
on Hollywood Squares.
(Rhett chuckles)
You knew he was gonna give a funny answer
and then you weren't supposed
to take it seriously,
everybody would laugh and
then he would give his answer
that you were gonna
agree or disagree with,
so this is something we do on our show.
When we play our whiteboard games,
we talk about, we kinda know that
sometimes we give funny
answers on the whiteboard,
sometimes we say funny answers
but then there's a different
answer on the whiteboard
like I was gonna say so and so
and maybe try to get a laugh.
All that comes from Hollywood Squares
and that's why I love it.
- I love all that stuff about it.
- I also love
the fact that it was lower
pressure for the contestants,
like something about me watching--
- Okay this is interesting.
This is what I wanted to
talk about so go ahead.
- Yeah and I think I'm
just now realizing this,
I also love the fact that
I feel like I could be
a contestant on that
and not just, my pants.
- And this says a lot
about our personalities
because the reason and I
figured that it would be higher
on your list,
if not number one.
- You have a 50/50 chance.
And I know how to play tic-tac-toe.
- The reason that it did
not get higher than four
on my list is because
there's not enough at stake.
- It's not truly competitive.
There's no skill.
- There's no drama.
Now, when you get to
what my number one is,
you might be like why's
that your number one,
and I'll try to justify it.
But the reason Hollywood Squares,
as great as all those
things that you described
about it are--
- I think I know what it is
but I'm not gonna say it
because I don't wanna spoil
your number one which--
- Well you might end
up spoiling it anyway.
- I would never do to you
what you just did to me.
- The reason is that
it's just fun.
- Yeah.
- It's only fun.
- Good Xs and Os fun.
- I don't remember any of the contestants.
There's no like, do you
remember when Ken Jennings
was winning for a month,
you know what I'm saying?
- Right, right.
- There's no opportunity
for the contestant to
excel in a way that brings
the attention back to them which again,
as somebody who's super
competitive and has had a life
of competing in sports and stuff like that
and drawing attention to myself,
I naturally kinda lock
into the game strategy
and how do you win this
and how are you the victor
in this and Hollywood
Squares didn't have that.
It had the comedy side which I love
and that's why it's on
my top five of all time,
but it's not higher because of that.
- And the resurgence of game shows,
the primetime game shows
where you're talking about,
what's the Howie Mandel box show?
- Deal or No Deal.
- I hope that's not on your list.
- It isn't, it is an honorable mention.
But I have a very specific
reason why it's not on my list.
- All right again I'm not gonna spoil
what I think is your number one--
- I'll wait until I get to--
- But I'm just gonna say--
- Another game show that
is a modern game show
and tell you why it is on my
list and why Deal or No Deal
is not on my list.
- The drama and the stakes
and the spotlight and all that stuff
from all those primetime shows,
the resurgence of game
shows in primetime--
- Is based on that premise.
- Is based on the principle
of drama and stakes.
- You can't get a primetime
game show that's just fun.
Doesn't work.
- Right, right.
They tried to bring back
The Gong Show which is not
on my list even though
I watched that some.
And I didn't like that 'cause
that was just frivolous.
That was basically just
like a crazy variety show,
I wasn't into that.
- They brought it back
with Mike Myers playing a character.
- It was too silly.
- That no one watching
network television understood
that that was a character.
- Yeah that was weird, I don't understand.
- Wrong crowd.
- What's, is it my turn?
- It's your turn to say
what your number four is.
- My number four is The Price Is Right.
- Hmm, okay.
- I think The Price Is Right
is the longest-running
game show in history.
Can you verify that?
At another point in my
life, when I was younger
and I couldn't be left alone
for any amount of time,
my mom took me to Miss Dean.
Miss Dean--
- Child care.
- Big blue Cadillac
that only had two doors
but the doors were so long,
it was like you would pull the door handle
and as a grade schooler
she'd pick me up from school,
I'd pull the door handle
open and then I would have
to walk in a circular radius in order to,
using all my weight to push the door open
and then get in the backseat
with three or four other kids.
Is it the longest-running
game show, yes, since when?
- '69.
- 1972.
- '72.
- Syndicated version.
'56 is when--
- Wow.
- It originally aired and that
was Bob Barker from the top,
I believe.
No he says.
We should have done some research.
- Who cares about research?
- Who cares.
This is all about my brain.
- It's happening now.
- Over the summer, when
she didn't pick me up
from school and I'd have
to walk her door open,
Mom would just drop me off and
I'd be there in the morning,
eat a little Rice Krispies
with a bunch of sugar added.
- At Miss Dean's?
- At Miss Dean's.
- She added sugar to your
Rice Krispies at Miss Dean's?
- I insisted upon it.
- Okay.
- I remember there was a
little television situated
right in front of her table
where we would eat breakfast
and everything and then,
we'd watch other stuff
but then ultimately,
Price Is Right would come
on at same time it does now.
- Yeah.
- 11 o'clock.
- Which is interesting
that that's its time slot and
that's what you associated
with that, watching Price Is
Right in the late morning.
But don't watch Wheel of Fortune
or Jeopardy in the late morning.
- I love Price Is Right,
I also think it has a heavy influence
on Good Mythical Morning.
But what would happen is, the
reason why it's not higher
for me even though I love it,
especially that big wheel, man.
That is awesome.
And I love Bob Barker, I
love his long microphone.
At the end of the episode, I knew,
we were eating lunch, she
would serve lunch at 11:40
and we would eat our
grilled cheese or whatever
and then I knew at the end
of the Showcase Showdown,
that I'm gonna have to
take a nap right after this
and that's the reason
that it's not higher.
She would make us take a nap--
- Seems a little unfair.
- At noon.
- To Price Is Right, hold
on, it's an hour-long show.
- An hour-long show and at the moment,
yeah you'd have a winner of the first,
first person would spin
the wheel and be like,
oh I like that guy, he's
gonna come back at the end
and then they'd bring more people up.
So at the end when he
was like, and remember,
have your pets spayed or neutered.
I was like, now I gotta lay down
and act like I'm going to sleep.
I hated it.
That's the only reason it's not higher.
- Pavlovian response to Bob
Barker's neutering call.
- The pandemonium when you would run down,
come on down, that was just exciting, man.
- Well okay so it's not
on my list and it was,
and I ended up knocking it
off to add another one that,
I don't know even know
how I feel about it.
- 'Cause Miss Dean would
make you take a nap at
noon which is cruel.
- I never even met her.
- You never met her?
- I don't think so.
Man, the more I think about it,
it has so many great elements.
Just let me just cover
'em for a second, right?
Very funny, quick-witted host.
You got the sex appeal of--
- The models.
- The Barker Beauties.
- There's male models now.
- Now there's male models,
yes, it's 2019, of course.
- It's great.
Bring it on.
- You've got a play-along-ability,
you've got the variety
of all the different games,
you've got lots of cash
and prizes, it's an hour long.
You've got the wheel, you've
got the Showcase Showdown,
it has so many elements.
- When Safe Cracker comes on
you get excited or of
course Plinko like woo!
- I honestly think that the
reason it didn't make my list
is the time of day that it comes on
that makes it feel less weighty to me.
- And the commercials
really bring you down.
- Lots of commercials
and they were always--
- They're marketed towards
people who are dying,
I mean honestly.
- And also I never,
I always found myself being annoyed
by the contestants in a
way that I was not annoyed,
and you know what, something
that Bob Barker didn't do--
- They're manic.
The contestants are manic.
- And he also, even though
he had a lot of dry wit,
I feel like he let, he
encouraged a lot of that.
Whereas other hosts
would kinda shut it down.
- He almost absorbed it
as personal adulation.
- And I don't know if I was jealous.
I don't know what it was but
there was something about
the whole system that turned me off enough
to make me not, 'cause one of the reasons,
one of the criteria for this list is
if I turn the channel to it,
which I still do turn
the channel sometimes.
- Oh I know what's up there for you now.
That you'll watch.
- If I land on it,
I will keep watching it
until it's over and so,
The Price Is Right is something
that I would tune out of.
I didn't have to watch it until the end,
so most of the stuff on my list,
or all of the stuff on
my list is something
that I will kind of lock into.
- Drew Carey.
- Drew Carey's whole career changed.
It was a complete career
change to step into that role.
- What's your next one?
I'd love to bid a dollar though.
You know iJustine?
- She's been on there.
- She was on there.
Of course they cast, they
look at everybody in line.
Hate to break this to
you but when you stand,
they decide who's gonna come up.
They cast you based on,
they pick people in line.
When you're standing in
line for Price Is Right,
they're interviewing people.
They're going down the aisle--
- It's profiling.
- They're profiling you,
they're interviewing you
and they're bringing you up there.
Oh you got a social media following?
Get up here, girl.
- Okay.
This is my one modern game show.
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire.
- Okay, this is the one that was...
Started the resurgence of game
shows in primetime I believe.
So dramatic.
- And I am talking about
the Regis Philbin version.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, is it--
- Meredith Vieira.
- Is it still on?
- I don't think it is, no.
- And here's why--
- Maybe in syndication
but Meredith Vieira took
over during the daytime.
- Okay so--
- Maybe, I don't know.
- When it came on--
- I watched it.
- The stakes were so high.
- Yes.
- You could win
a million dollars.
Unlike anything that had ever happened
on a game show before.
It was nerve-racking, there
was a spotlight on this person.
They had to call the right person.
They had to make the right decisions.
They used their lifelines
and then you've got this
incredibly funny host,
you've got that, so it
isn't like you have this,
there was The Weakest Link
and you had that really--
- British.
- Caustic woman.
- British woman.
- And she was very funny
but it was just all--
- It was a bit.
- It was all a bit
the whole time and Regis,
I've always liked him.
I always liked Regis.
- Yeah.
I see a lot of your dad in Regis.
- Right.
He always, what do we got here?
- Started August 16th, 1999.
- 1999.
So anyway--
- Still in syndication,
of course.
- High playability factor,
play-along-ability factor
and the reason that I put
that on the list is because
it has all those elements.
The reason I did not put
Deal or No Deal on the list
is because that whole thing
where they make an offer to you
and they act like the woman up there,
the silhouette of the woman
and she's on the phone
and she's talking to Howie.
- Yeah.
- I don't like all that stuff
that I know is just all for show.
You know what I'm saying,
there was something about
the simplicity of this person in a chair
and these questions and a few
different things you could do
to get the answer and you
either keep going up or you go.
- It was over-sensationalized
but it wasn't like a farce.
- It wasn't a farce and there's
a farce in Deal or No Deal
and also--
- But I gotta give it
to Howie because I really think
that he was amazing on that show.
- Oh yeah.
- Absolutely--
- It's an honorable mention
but it's not in my top five.
- I didn't put it anywhere
but I gotta give it to...
The winking drama that he brought to it.
He kinda winked at--
- Howie is a genius
at playing into that thing.
- So good, man.
And the fact that a comedian
coming in and doing that
but the comedy was in how
dramatic he was, you know,
he actually wasn't funny
in the way you thought
he was gonna be funny.
- Hmm.
- He was funny in a
dramatic way, you know?
- Yeah but I think it
might be funny for you
to watch it 'cause you
know that he's acting
with these people too.
It might not be the way--
- Well I think--
- Everyone--
- No of course not.
- Interacts with--
- But it worked on that level.
And of course he knew that.
- So anyway, and I didn't, again,
nothing against Meredith.
I'm talking about the
Regis Philbin version
because Regis was funny.
- He was first.
- And I she wasn't trying to be funny.
- I don't recall.
- He was just trying
to be nice.
- I don't know what she was.
I'm staying out of that one.
- But I'm just saying, she
wasn't trying to be funny.
Regis is a comedian.
And so there's just something about how--
- I think she was funny.
- You need that voice
in there, I don't think
she was trying to be,
was she trying to be
funny, did you watch that?
- There's so few--
- She's not a comedian.
She's a host.
- There's so few female
game show hosts, like all of that '70s
and '80s bravado stuff which
now is almost intolerable.
I think it's like, so
I'll give it to Meredith
in terms of being a champion of--
- And of course, you're
trying to make me look bad.
- No I'm sorry, I know you aren't--
- It has nothing to do with--
- You just said that
she wasn't funny to you which is fine.
- No--
- You're sexist.
- She's not trying to be funny.
(Link chuckles)
She's not trying to be
funny, she's an anchor.
She's a news anchor, she's not a comedian.
So I'm saying that--
- She was endearing.
- You need a comedian in that
role to give the full package
for that show in my mind.
Once you got rid of that it was like
I'm not interested in it anymore.
- My number three.
I might be stealing your number one here.
- Okay.
- My number three is Family Feud.
- That's my number one.
- That's your number one?
- Mm-hmm.
- But I don't think it is
your number one because
I'm saying Family Feud
hosted by Richard Dawson.
- Okay, Family Feud hosted by
Richard Dawson was awesome.
Family Feud hosted by
Ray Combs was awesome.
- I don't know about that.
- Family Feud hosted by
the guy who was the beard
on Home Improvement--
- That's not--
- Not good.
- That's an improper use of the term.
- The bearded guy.
- The bearded guy is better.
- But and then Steve frickin' Harvey?
- Steve Harvey is amazing.
- The reason that this is my number one
is because it has stood the test of time.
- Yeah.
- And it also has stood
the test of the internet.
Family Feud unlike any other game show,
creates amazing fodder
for tantalizing internet compilations.
- Yeah.
- Of answers
and responses from the host.
- It's great.
- And it's just always fun.
It's fun but you're not just getting it
from professional comedians like you do
on Hollywood Squares,
you're getting it from
normal people, really racking their brains
to come up with what three
people out of 100 said.
That's when it gets interesting.
- Do you believe that by the way?
Do you believe they're actually going out
and they're asking 100 people stuff?
- There are people that do surveys, man.
- I think sometimes those
people who they ask are writers.
- Well sure.
- That's what I believe.
And it doesn't matter.
- It's just 100 people.
- Yeah they rack their
brains and they trap them
in these places where they
have to say embarrassing,
sexually-charged--
- Well in the last decade or
do, they really have leaned
into the innuendo and
they're actually doing it
for the internet clips,
in fact, sometimes,
Steve Harvey will be like,
"You gonna be on YouTube,"
you know what I'm saying.
He says it on the--
- And he's great.
The way that he, he is great, man.
That's his place, that's his calling.
- And there's just
something about the group,
this is another thing, the group effect.
You gotta come as a family so you have
to bring the weird brother or
the weird uncle, you have to.
You gotta have five people.
- The frickin' Kardashians
went on there with Kanye.
- You put the weird one down at the end.
- Did that really happen?
- Yes it did.
- I can't even believe that happened.
- It's the best game show, man.
- When Snoop was on there.
Now that's a clip you can keep watching.
- Yeah, exactly, so--
- So great.
- Unlike,
would Kanye and the Kardashians
go on Wheel of Fortune?
Well you can't really I guess.
- I think they went on more than one--
- Kim and Kanye could go on together but
there's a reason that
celebrities are clamoring,
and I add myself to
that list of people who,
I wanna go on that frickin' show.
- Let's face off.
My family against your family.
- Okay.
You got one extra.
No, I need an extra.
I've only got four people in my family.
Have to bring the dog.
- You're gonna have to
bring somebody weird.
- Again, it passes the test of if it's on,
I'm gonna watch it and I
think it depends so much on--
- I'm not gonna seek it out
but if it's on, I'll watch it.
- No--
- It's that good.
- You flip through and you find something.
I was at a restaurant--
- I'll seek it out on YouTube.
- I was at a restaurant
recently when we were skiing
and this restaurant was
playing the Family Feud,
I was like they've got it figured out.
I don't wanna see necessarily
the latest baseball game.
Show me Family Feud, man.
And it's so, the host has, this
is another reason I like it
is that I always secretly
wanted to be a game show host
and see myself in that role
and I see the way somebody
like Steve Harvey does it
and I'm just like hmm, that's--
- That's it.
- He's got it.
He's doing it.
The way he's interacting with
these people, it's perfect.
And so I kinda, I love
watching that process happen.
Family Feud.
FF, number one.
- I love the way that those
answers used to turn manually.
It was very satisfying.
- What do they do now?
- It's a screen.
- Bloop!
- Boring.
- They used to go ding and turn over.
- Yeah it was very satisfying
the way it would work.
All right so I need your number three.
- Oh.
- Number two.
- You need my number two.
Jeopardy.
- Jeopardy.
Now,
why you like Jeopardy?
Jeopardy's not on my list,
it's not on my honorable
mentions but it is a staple.
Whenever I'd go to Nanny's,
they would always be watching it.
I mean there's so many
people that watch it.
- For completely different reasons.
Obviously.
- What do you mean obviously?
- It's completely
different than Family Feud.
- Oh, oh.
- It is so dry.
- Yes.
- It is just smart people.
You have to be very smart to
qualify to be on Jeopardy.
You don't just pay a fee or something.
You have to pass a test.
- But why?
- To be on Jeopardy.
- I knew one guy who was almost on.
But I haven't known anybody who's on.
- There was a rumor for a
long time that my granddad
was gonna be on Jeopardy,
I remember that back
when I was kid, it was
like Grandpa McLaughlin,
he's gonna be on Jeopardy,
might be on Jeopardy.
I was like okay, cool.
I didn't like it as a kid.
- Why?
I don't understand the
broad appeal of a show
that is so heady.
- That is the appeal.
- I think it's 'cause you get the answers
right after the question so
you don't really play along.
I remember--
- No no.
- You play along--
- Hold on,
the appeal is trivia.
It's the only game that's based on,
predicting what 100 people
are gonna say in a survey
to a question is not trivia.
But Jeopardy is trivia.
It's like this category--
- You learn--
- About Greek mythology, you're like, oh.
- You learn fascinating stuff.
- What do I remember
about that and I think
everyone is accessing
their knowledge base and
I think there's just a lot
of people that A, like
to play along with that,
to be like, what category would I pick
and how much do I know about
this and can I get the answer
before they get the answer without,
in Groundhog Day having
seen it a million times,
but also, seeing somebody do
what a guy like Ken Jennings
and apparently there's a
guy that just did it again.
I haven't been watching.
- Breaking the records of winnings, yes.
- Yeah seeing somebody
dominate in that way
just because they are just
smarter than other people
is something that people like
to watch, I like to watch,
that's why it's number two.
- The way that he's winning so much
and this has been done before is that
they skip around in
categories to keep everybody
on their heels and they try
to find the daily doubles
early knowing that they're
not gonna be the low values
and then they're really
smart on what to wager.
You can wager everything you've got
and take risks earlier and really assert,
acquire a big lead and if
you don't get it right,
you can recover because you're
still in charge of the game
and everyone's on their heels.
And so that's kind of a known--
- He's changed the game.
- It's a known technique now.
Yeah, I'm just fascinated with people
who aren't heady thinkers,
still like to witness trivia answers.
I think that's what it teaches me is that
you don't have to be a reader
or honestly a very thoughtful person
to really enjoy bite-sized trivia.
It's a different thing.
- Well I actually think
that most people who like it
do think of themselves as,
whether they are or they aren't,
they are interested in thinking
about where they stack up
against other people.
I think that that's the appeal
and I think that's most people.
I think most people when they, again,
I think most people are
relatively competitive.
I think that it's just like,
okay you're gonna ask a question?
I'm compelled.
My human nature compels
me to give you an answer
and to try to give you that answer
before somebody else does.
- I was laying in bed,
I think I was laying in bed,
and this thought popped into
my head, I don't know why.
Maybe I was reading something
on Reddit about Jeopardy.
Unrelated to what I was reading,
I was like why is it formatted
that you answer, you
don't answer a question.
You respond to an answer with a question.
So I looked that up 'cause I
couldn't formulate a guess.
I couldn't figure out why
that would be the case.
- Did you formulate a question?
- So according to the Smithsonian,
in 1963 television host and
erstwhile actor Merv Griffin
was flying back to New York
City with his wife Julann
after a weekend visiting
her parents in Michigan.
Didn't need to add that but they did.
Merv was looking at
notes for a new game show
and Julann asked if it was one
of the knowledge-based games
she likes so is it a trivia game?
He said, "Since The $64,000 Question,
"the network won't let you
do those anymore," he said.
The rigging scandal of the 1950s,
like that movie Quiz Show.
- Yeah.
- Which very good movie.
The scandals had killed
off American quiz shows
seemingly for good.
And he said, "They suspect you
of giving them the answers."
And she said something to the effect of,
"Well why don't you give them the answers
"and people make up the questions."
And he's like thinking
about it, he's like okay,
the answer is 5,280.
And he thought for a moment.
The question is, how many feet in a mile.
And he's like, the answer
is 79 Whistful Vista.
The then the response was,
where did Fibber McGee and Molly live?
I don't know who Fibber McGee is.
This was in 1963.
Those two simple questions
changed TV history.
There you have it.
It was just a simple
response but it was such a,
it was a hook, and then I'm thinking,
well, if you give an answer,
you could ask multiple
questions to get that answer.
So then I'm realizing that you've got to,
you also have to satisfy the category.
- Right.
- So you gotta satisfy
the clue and the category
so if it's like there was one that was,
Patrick Roy and Hope Solo
played this position.
And the category was 10 letter words.
- 10 letter words?
- Yeah, and the answer--
- Goalkeeper.
What is a goalkeeper?
- Wrong.
- What is a goalie?
- Goalkeeper is 10 letters,
but they said it had
to contain the word 10
so the correct answer was goaltender.
- Oh it had to contain, oh that's great.
- But they said that so
there's my little trivia.
- Wow.
- Associated with Jeopardy
and we--
- That's great though.
What you just did is great.
That's what makes it so great.
- Yeah and I don't think--
- It's a mind game, man.
- When they were
brainstorming it on the plane,
I don't think they knew
the full ramifications.
Sometimes you just, what
if we give the answer
and you have to come up with the question
and then you play it out--
- Which ultimately,
they're just asking a question
and you're giving the answer
but they just reverse
sort of the pretense.
Now, of course--
- We gotta talk about Alex.
- Alex Trebek has got
pancreatic cancer.
As of the recording of this--
- Sending much love to Alex.
- Alec.
- Oh. (chuckles)
I like--
- Send it to the right person.
(Link laughs)
- Alec.
- He's got pancreatic cancer
which of course is like...
- It is Alex.
Yeah hold on, it's not Alec.
I thought it's Alec Baldwin.
I was sending it to the right person
and then you fooled me.
- Alex Trebek.
I don't know.
- I kept thinking--
- Here's the thing.
- It is Alex.
- Here's the thing, up until literally,
I've never thought that
his name was Alec until
a split second ago when you said Alex.
I've always known him to be Alex Trebek.
- I just have a way of making
you think sounds false.
- You made it sound wrong.
(chuckles)
- That's a game show.
Making true things sound false.
- He's got pancreatic
cancer which is you know,
very, very low survival rate.
- He made a heart-wrenching
announcement video.
They haven't said who's
gonna replace him because--
- Well what's the latest though because
I don't know what the status
of his health is right now.
- I don't know the status of
his health but in terms of,
they're not saying who would replace him.
I think they're keepin'
all that under wraps but--
- Maybe a guy named Alec.
- I feel like if he has a son,
I think his son should do
it and I think that his son
should look just like him but
have the mustache that he had
in the '80s.
- And we don't know,
I mean he could beat this illness.
But he's going to retire
at some point regardless.
- Sure, rumors are saying that
Gayle King will replace him.
Somehow that name's floating around.
- What's it say?
- He signed off for the summer
but he intends on coming back.
'Cause he's saying I'm gonna beat this.
But even when he retires,
we wish Alex the best
and we believe he can do it.
I wouldn't wanna host.
- The way that you said it
somehow tricked my brain
into thinking that it was
Alec, that's incredible.
You have a gift, man.
- Thank you.
- But we've covered, we've
covered your number--
- I gotta go with
my number two.
- Oh your number two.
- My number two 'cause Hollywood
Squares is my number one,
my number two is Press Your Luck.
Because that was--
- The Whammies.
- That was my favorite show.
No Whammies no Whammies no Whammies, stop!
- Yeah that was an
honorable mention for me.
- It was very manic.
Peter Tomarken was the host.
And this guy had the slyest grin.
It was like he knew something.
And I never figured out what it was.
And I couldn't stop watching
because I thought maybe I'd figure it out.
Like he knew something about life
and it was very amusing to him.
Something about this weird,
bemused bravado was just,
I don't know, I just thought
he was the coolest guy.
- Tarken.
- Tomarken.
- Peter Tomarken.
- I can't picture him right now.
- And they would have the
animations on the screen
where the Whammies would come out or the--
- Yeah those little
devil-looking characters.
- Devil guys would come out.
- Tasmanian devils.
- It would do different stuff.
And we talked on GMM about one
of our most-viewed
episodes ever was like--
- The cheater.
- Game show cheaters.
And the guy on Price Is
Right who was the cheater,
he died recently and that
was back in the news.
Flanagan sent that to us.
I don't know why that video
kept getting 10s of millions
of views on our channel, it's crazy.
- People just like--
- But we also talked about--
- Cheaters.
- The guy who cheated
on Press Your Luck and
he knew the patterns
and could--
- He could time it perfectly.
- Stop at the right time.
I just like the energy of it.
And they would make it
look like the contestants
and the host were perched on top
of this huge board with the way that
they would superimpose it.
- It was the first game show
that had, I think they did
this with Bumper Stumpers too
if I remember, the display of it--
- Like a picture.
- Was a picture
in picture thing.
Very interesting.
- But basically, it's my
number two just because
of his, Peter Tomarken's vibe,
the animations and just the
overall, just the energy.
- I don't even remember what
the point of the show was.
- The vibe of the show.
- What was the point of the show?
- I don't know.
Win money. (chuckles)
- But you were pressing
your luck and you were like
I'm gonna go again, I'm gonna
hit this thing and then--
- It would build up, the
pressure would build up
in terms of are you gonna
lose all this money?
- Okay so that's your number two.
- Yeah.
- So we don't agree
on the number one, you
said Hollywood Squares,
I said Family Feud.
Honorable mentions that we didn't mention
that you may remember, Street Smarts.
Do you remember Street Smarts?
This is like--
- That was on Fox.
- Early 2000s.
- That seemed trashy to me but
I don't remember what it is.
- Well it was a game, there was a host,
can't remember his name, who
would go out on the street
and do man on the street
interviews with people
and then there was two contestants
and they had to predict
if this person was,
of these three contestants
that we just introduced you to,
which one of them will know who this is?
And they hold up a picture
and it's like Frank Sinatra.
And it's just like, okay,
which one of these people,
only one of them knew
who Frank Sinatra was,
which one was it and so then you pick one
of the three people.
- So it's profiling.
- And then they show you and they say,
and just for fun, let's
see what Carla said.
And she doesn't know who Frank Sinatra is
so she says like the president
or something like that.
- Man on the street comedy.
- So it's making fun
of stupid people which is like what now
Jimmy Kimmel has turned
into a bit with his man
on street stuff where it's
like, what do people know
about current politics or whatever.
It was very trashy.
- One of my honorable mentions
was Supermarket Sweep.
I don't know why as a
kid I had any business
being interested in Supermarket Sweep.
- It's funny because you were
so averse at spending money
and have always been but yet
you wanted to see somebody else
go do it.
- Oh yeah wish fulfillment.
Like oh my gosh, if I had
a cart and 90 seconds,
what would I get?
And I think on Nickelodeon
there was a show
where you would go into Toys
R Us and do the same thing,
you go to a toy store.
- That makes sense.
- But yeah I would
watch the adult version,
Supermarket Sweep.
- Speaking of Nickelodeon,
Double Dare was on there.
- Yeah, Double Dare.
- Not top five but it's so iconic.
- My honorable mention was Fun House,
the Fox television show
ripoff of Double Dare
with the host had red hair
and he's been the host
of other things too.
Can you Google the hose of Fun House?
- I never even heard of it.
- Just picture a ripoff of Double Dare.
- And that beat Double Dare for you?
- I think it had bigger obstacle courses
that were more like,
it was more like American
Ninja Warrior in some ways,
I think in the final.
J.D. Roth was the host.
- And then I had The Newlywed
Show and The Dating Game.
Kinda before our time so reruns
and then those clips pop up a bunch
but it's just one of those things
that endless fodder for compilations.
- Tic-Tac-Dough.
- Never heard of it.
- Wink Martindale hosted that.
- Oh.
- It was tic-tac-toe
like Hollywood Squares
but it was different in
ways I can't remember
but Wink Martindale, he
hosted a bunch of shows
and he was hokey,
but I liked him.
You got any other honorable mentions,
you're done?
- No I'm done with
my honorable mentions.
- Oh you're done?
Shout out to $25,000 Pyramid, Dick Clark.
I like that, you'd have
a celebrity paired--
- It's a good show.
- With a contestant
and it would be things like, crystal ball.
Magic eight ball.
- Round things.
(chuckles)
Magic round things.
- Fortune teller.
- Magic things.
(chuckles)
- We suck at this.
A prognosticator.
A, pass.
- Prophecy.
- It was things that predict the future.
- Things that predict the future.
- Yeah.
And then some people would
be really good at it.
- Not us.
- There were some celebrities
who didn't have anything
better to do so they stayed on the show
and then they would get really good at it.
- Right, it's good, have they tried
to bring that back, right?
- I don't know but they should again.
I think that's all on
my honorable mentions.
Concentration, that was
the last one that I added.
It was like a matching
game and you would remove
matching panels and it
would reveal a pictograph
underneath that--
- It's a matching game.
- Like a phrase.
And you had to solve it,
solve the phrase using the pictographs.
I loved that game for some reason.
So that's it.
- Yeah those sorta--
- Now we agree.
- Simple, simple games.
- So we agree on Family Feud.
- Simple games like that just won't,
they won't put 'em on television anymore.
- Well there's a whole network.
- They'll put 'em on
television in Australia.
Based on what I saw--
- Yeah what you saw.
- When I was there.
- So there you have it.
Our top game shows of all times.
Let us know, all time.
We've only had one time.
Go to #EarBiscuits, let us
know your favorite game show
and tell us why, maybe
it'll change our minds.
Maybe it'll remind us of
something or give us a reason
or a piece of trivia that will
make us change our top five.
- And Link, do you have a rec?
Do you have a Rec In Effect?
- I do, I got a Rec In Effect.
Since you're done
listening to this podcast,
maybe you want another
podcast to listen to
before Ear Biscuits rolls around next week
'cause you're fully caught up.
I'm gonna recommend a
podcast where you can listen
to my wife talk for an hour.
- Wow.
- Our good friend Mike has a podcast
called Ask Science Mike.
I highly recommend his podcast in general,
but episode 180 called
Living, I wrote it down here,
I didn't remember exactly.
Living With a Brain Injury with
Christy Neal who's my wife.
I don't know that I've ever
actually shared specifically
that almost three years ago
Christy suffered a brain injury.
She suffers from post-concussion
syndrome as a result
of a concussion she had
almost three years ago
which dramatically changed
her life as well as
had ramifications for us as a family.
We've been talking about
when was the right time
maybe for her to come on Ear
Biscuits and talk about it.
But she didn't wanna do it
because of the video component,
honestly.
She wasn't quite ready for that.
She doesn't love being on
the videos at this point.
So Ask Science Mike, check
that out, episode 180.
Especially if you know
someone who's had a concussion
or has suffered from an invisible injury
that impacts your life, I
think there's lots of takeaways
and I'm super proud of her
for everything she shared.
I think it's tremendously,
it can be really powerful
to someone who's going through it
or knows someone who is so check that out.
And I think that's all I have
to say about it at this time.
I do think that at some point,
maybe she'll come on the air,
we can unpack it further.
But that's a great place
to start, so check it out.
- And with that being said,
we will see you again.
Or you will hear us again
or hear and see us again,
however you enjoy this, next week.
In the meantime, connect with us.
The password is #EarBiscuits.
- No Whammies!
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)